welcome into safety blitz starring the
two-time super bowl champion rodney
harrison and rob we have to start with
the breaking news coming out of the nfc
east that has been the buzz all year
long and now dwayne haskins when you are
one game away from a playoff push the
washington football team
cuts moves on from dwayne haskins the
15th overall pick how do you take the
move
i thought it was i thought it was the
right move to make i would have cut him
after i heard of the situation i would
have never let him come in after what he
went through and
you know start a football game ron
rivera is trying to establish a culture
and the last thing you want or need is
your quarterback who's the captain of
the team breaking uh protocols and to me
it just shows the immaturity of dwayne
haskins he's not ready for the moment
and he really blew a golden opportunity
i mean think it's not many starting
quarterbacks in the national football
league and he blew an opportunity to
start in the national football league
and i just tell you this man
i was very very disappointed
because
as a black quarterback part of his
responsibility is doing everything he
can to be successful to encourage and to
give others an opportunity and you don't
want to discourage other organizations
from taking a chance on other black
quarterbacks because you screwed up so
it's not just about you dwayne haskins
but it's your responsibility to all
those other black quarterbacks trying to
come up and fight and make it for an
opportunity to play quarterback in the
national football league
rod how about when you just watch him on
the field if you can isolate it down to
his play
on the football field what has he shown
you has he's shown you enough to where
another team should now give haskins a
chance or is this just an isolated off
the field incident or two that
ultimately led to this how do you take
the combination of where we are now i
don't think i don't think that this is
an isolated incident because if you
understood the magnitude of what he did
if he had the maturity to understand
that they're fighting for a division
title they're fighting for an
opportunity to get into the playoffs and
you mean to tell me everything else
on your radar is more important than
putting all the time and effort as a
backup quarterback with an opportunity
to start all in 100 into preparing what
about getting on zoom for the
you know three or four hours that you
wasted at the strip club or having the
party or whatever it's just stupid you
know you're in the middle of a playoff
hunt and that's your priority so to me
he's gonna get another opportunity
because he was a 15th pick overall and
he has talent but he's he's a very
immature kid and he needs to grow up and
i think this might do it for him
well here's the downside this is one of
the most quarterback needy teams in the
entire nfl and this is this is it when
you're looking at a team that has great
defense great defensive line they've
really put a ton of resources into
making sure that they can get a pass
rush with those four on the front of the
defensive line and that's why that
they're in this position i know that the
nfc east is on a way down year but this
defense has kept them in it
and for haskins this is the exact kind
of opportunity you want to be in where
you can
get chances that you wouldn't typically
get they don't have a full-time starter
there alex smith is banged up this is
perfect and this is just perfect
and and you kind of blew it you know and
i think as the 15th overall pick in
general
you can't really do anything there's so
many eyeballs on you in the city where
you were drafted so if you're going to
go out even to go to a bar or something
you're going to get blow back on that
but in the cove year to go do something
like you you just can't leave your house
i mean you just can't you pretty much
just have to sit at home and if you're
going to leave expect that you're going
to be on camera the entire time that
you're out of your house that's just the
nature of the world that we're living in
right now and so maybe haskins does get
another shot but when you're one game
away from a playoff push on a team that
desperately needs any hope at the
quarterback position
i don't know who that team is that now
wants to give you a chance i think it's
clear riverboat ron rivera is now making
the decisions in washington and not dan
snyder because this was snyder's guy in
haskins
absolutely and i love what ron rivera is
doing he's sending a clear message to
the locker room he's letting everybody
know that if you don't fall in line if
you don't do what you're supposed to do
i don't care if you're a captain i don't
care if you're a quarterback i don't
care if you're the 15th pick overall
last year um you're not going to be
around so you know to me i i also look
at the fact he has to realize that
you're professional football players
it's like 2 000 professional football
players okay roughly
and if you're the starting quarterback
you have to understand it like you just
talked about all the tension all the
eyes are on you
so as a backup quarterback you have no
other choice but to go all in studying
preparing talking to your quarterback
coach talking to your offensive
coordinator spending all that extra time
why would something like that even be on
your mind and have the opportunity i
have an opportunity to play with terry
mclaren antonio gibson
um logan thomas a young defense those
guys up front to be the quarterback of
the washington football team you're
going to have an opportunity to win many
many games in the future because you see
what ron rivera is building down there a
great culture with good people that you
can rely on that's accountable and i'm
just really disappointed with um dwayne
haskins because it didn't have to um
play out like this zach
it is crazy that he could go from
starter to waved on monday you know like
starter that's barely enough time to
even watch the film before he's the nfl
man it's the nfl it's the nfl and it
felt like for for coach rivera this was
sort of last chance opportunity for him
and there was just a couple balls in
that game i'm thinking about the flag
route he just way under thrown just ugly
very turnover worthy interceptions and
his only real completions that you saw
were short think dunk stuff uh and his
mobility is there but it's not quite
there with the caliber of lamar jackson
or kyler murray or he's not that top
shelf of mobility he's somewhere sort of
in between wentz uh kind of a caliber
guy when he takes off and runs so he's
just was stuck right there in between
and it didn't work out in washington
we'll see what happens he's still so
young so you think that there has to be
at least potential for a future for
dwayne haskins moving forward let's go
from you know one of the toughest
quarterback rooms yeah yeah go ahead
finish that though no no go ahead i'm
good i'm good
all right cool i was just gonna say
let's take it from one of the tougher
quarterback rooms to one of the best the
green bay packers very well may have
taken over this mvp race as aaron
rodgers kansas city's offense down the
stretch has slowed all the way down
while green bays has heated up that was
one of the more impressive as a guy
that's played in the snow
how about the show we just saw from
aaron rodgers this green bay team in the
snowy sunday night football last night
and let me just tell you this this is
the reason like last night was
a perfect example of why
aaron rodgers and the packers they're
gonna win against chicago okay and why
it's so important for them to keep that
number one seed because if you don't
play in that crap if you don't practice
in it you're not gonna be successful in
it and you saw rogers and those guys
having a blast running the ball throwing
the ball aj dillon
he can really be that x factor that
they're looking for he's big he's a
thick powerful back that can wear a
defense down i just think that the green
bay packers man when you start looking
at the teams in the nfc i like the green
bay packers at this point in time
because like you talked about aaron
rodgers is playing out of his mind
devonte adams aaron jones
aj dillon i mean they just have weapon
after weapon now you're getting some of
these young receivers that are big and
athletic stepping up making plays and
aaron rodgers looked like he's having
the most fun of his career it's it's
awesome to see
for green bay it looked like it was
sunny in 75 on that field last night
it looked like look at they're playing
in alaska underneath 10 feet of snow
just the contradiction between both
those teams on the same football field
was something to see so let's hear from
aaron rodgers on the win on davonte
adams who quietly 17 touchdown season
that he has put together despite missing
a couple games he's just been on fire
here was a rod the mvp favorite as it
sits
i think we've all heard about the
conversation about us not being enough
good teams and
uh you know not responding and playing a
complete game and
this was our response being with that
guy is it's allowed me to
you know know what true greatness is
yeah you see um davonte adams he just
continues his monster season and what i
love about those guys they have so much
respect and the understanding both those
guys are the same they work their butts
off you can see every time devonta adams
catches a pass from aaron rodgers he's
beating a cornerback down he's he's
shoving a linebacker he's trying to make
the safety miss it's just it's just
really nice to see that they've kind of
found their niche and you include the
run game with robert tunyan and tight
end and all the other different weapons
they have
as well as that defense that defense
kind of got ignited and you know once
they get ahead and then those pass
rushers you can unleash those pass
rushers man it's pretty special what
they're building down there
rashaan gary's really turning into
something defensively zadaria smith has
been something for them defensively so
now they have the combination of those
two guys playing at a high level uh and
everybody showed up last night for the
derrick henry show this was going to be
the derrick henry power running
performance for him to go take over in
prime time and everybody in the world
could enjoy it in the snow and instead
it was aj dylan and we haven't seen him
get more than five carries in a single
game all season long not more than five
and he went off last night on sunday
night football and everybody kind of
been wondering why use a second round
pick why use such a great resource on a
power running back when you already have
aaron jones and the reason is there may
only be one real home field advantage in
the nfl this year and that home field
advantage might be the weather in green
bay that may be the only home field
advantage as we come down the home
stretch and what could be better than a
250 pound power running back to go along
with mvp aaron rodgers i mean that is a
lot to think about when you slow you sit
down and start how are we going to
defend the green bay packers in the
freezing cold you have to think about
that power running game to go along with
what they're doing through the air green
bay looks like a dangerous team headed
to tampa right now
and you know what i like about them is
there's no jealousy there's no envy on
the team like when it doesn't matter if
aj dylan scoring a touchdown aaron jones
aaron everybody's so happy and you know
just really excited for everyone that's
uh making contributions and and you know
in order to get to that next level you
need that level of love trust and that
unselfishness um amongst your team in
order to get to that next level jack
you do so jared goff and now we've seen
the rams let's let's transition it to
the rams real quick and really into
seattle too so with the rams we just saw
him lose to the jets and that is a way
of magnifying a lot of issues that you
have going on it's a team that's been
playing awesome defense awesome defense
top three defense in the league but
jared goff continues to hold him hold
them back on the offensive side why do
you think that is what's going on with
them now that they've lost two in a row
well he's just not that good and you
know he's been so inconsistent and at
times
he looks very comfortable and he can
deliver the ball and he's got receivers
and run game when the run game is gone
he's a really good quarterback but if
they can't run the football especially
with the injury to cam akers if they
can't run the football then he struggles
off those bootlegs and play action
passes and things like that so when you
look at jared goff man and we've seen it
in the super bowl you just seen times
where it's like this dude is he's
garbage but then other times you look
and say man this dude could be the next
tom brady but he's just it's just a
level of inconsistency and i just think
that he needs to you know get get his
confidence back once he gets his
confidence back then he can play because
he has a lot of weapons he can throw to
and he has a really good defense like
you alluded to
and you have to wonder too if they paid
him too early it's a similar situation
with wence in philadelphia both of those
quarterback situations they could have
waited on another year or two and seen
is this our guy should we let him play
out the fifth year option and make
certain that this is the quarterback we
want to invest 100 million plus into
both of those franchises the rams and
the eagles decided we're going to pay
them early lock up our quarterback go
build the rest of our team
only issue with all that is the
quarterback they locked up so far has
regressed since signing those contracts
so let's hear from sean mcvay on his
quarterback who now has a thumb injury
too as he dislocates the thumb pops it
right back in on that game on sunday
there's some crazy stuff coming down the
home stretch for the rams here was
mcveigh after a loss
i'm not sure right now i don't want to
speculate on that uh i know he battled
and uh
i really have a lot of respect for the
toughness that he exuded today to be
able to finish that game out and
you know that's really all i can say on
that it's it's not terrible um we'll see
you tomorrow we'll we'll evaluate
tomorrow we've got
you know 24 hours to see what happens
kind of but um yeah we'll be we'll see
you know it's amazing too a month ago we
were just talking about the rams
probably as the most complete team in
the nfc or one of the most complete
teams in the nfc they were running the
ball they were playing defense jared
goff was playing well now all of a
sudden they take a step back and he does
if he doesn't play this week then they
have to go to a backup quarterback that
doesn't have a lot of experience and i
just think the rams are in trouble right
now and if they if they can't run the
football if their defense can't come up
with two or three turnovers with the
unproven commodity at the quarterback
position i think they're going to
struggle
i i do too and by the same token seattle
looked pretty smooth and this was
you know you know what he does so well
talking about russell wilson is he makes
defenders stuck in no man's land he does
it so consistently in a game like this
he's just a proven closer as russell
wilson in the same way ben
roethlisberger was a closer on yesterday
just figuring out a way to go win a
close game like this and i thought what
russell did so impressively is he just
leaves guys what is he going to run is
he going to throw and he really doesn't
make up his mind and he forces you as
the defender to make up your mind so you
come up and just go rush him and go
there's no way i'm going to let him
scramble for this first down and he
flips it right over your head to the
tight end and the next time you decide
to stand back in coverage and stay on
that tight end and then russell runs for
15 20 yards so that's where he he just
plays games with defenses he did it to
the rams just enough in that big goal
line stand that the seattle defense was
able to get to in order to get the ball
back but this this was just a russ go be
a closer go figure out a way to just
score enough points to get it done
that's exactly what it did 20 to 9 in
the final
yeah and and it's not about let russ
cook but to me the defense really
stepped up and really won this ball game
for me jamal adams he's been absolutely
terrific he's brought a level of energy
and he's brought a standard think about
it i don't even remember the last time i
talked about bobby wagner and bobby
wagner's going to be a hall of famer and
since jamal adams has come in that's all
we ever talk about he's he's a safety i
mean the play that he made yesterday and
he came off the edge and he tackled the
running back short before he got into
the gold
to score a touchdown and he basically
saved the touchdown that was the play of
the game nobody talks about it i said it
yesterday on sunday night football but
that was the play of the game and it
just shows you how tremendous that
that jamal adams he's playing i mean
he's just he's playing out of his mind
right now he's playing faster than
anybody more physical than anybody he's
been outstanding for him and he gave up
a lot for him and and it's returning
dividends upon
they did he basically plays linebacker i
mean when you sit there and watch him
play i mean how often does it seem like
he's lined up in that box he's really
the closest thing that i see right now
to a troy palamalu running around the
end he's defensive he's a defensive
defensive end he pass rushes uh and
you're mentioning that goal line stand
where it was like seven or eight plays
in ropes they had gotten the first down
right around the three or four yard line
there's like seven or eight plays in a
row where this seattle defense just held
him quarterback sneak run around the
edge it was wide open jamal adams is
chasing from behind
every single one of those plays it
seemed like jamal adams was such a
factor down around the line of scrimmage
like you're saying in a 20-9 playoff
type game
two teams same division battling for one
of those spots
those are the goal line stands that can
swing the momentum and i'll tell you
what else the seattle defense did was
that they were only rushing three or
four throughout the vast majority of the
game and just dropping seven or eight
and really covering these rams wide
receivers and golf didn't have anything
to counter that he there was there was
no there was nothing coming back from
mcveigh and from golf that was counter
balancing what the seattle defense was
doing and you're just starting to see
you maybe we saw the same thing in the
super bowl where bill belichick had
caught up to golf and mcvay with a
couple of things so there's just now
starting to become holes in this rams
attack that they're not multiple they
don't have something else they can go to
to get out of and that's why we're
seeing this kind of up and down season
from them all the way throughout
and and what else it does is it takes
that pressure off of russell wilson
because russell doesn't feel like
remember when russell and the defense
struggled he didn't really trust the
defense it almost felt like he felt like
he had they had to score 30 plus points
every game and the defense has stepped
up so much now it's taking pressure off
of russell so now he doesn't have to
feel like he has to throw the ball down
the field you know seven or eight times
to get a 70 yard bomb that he can be
patient that he can actually make a
mistake and his defense will be there
for him so i like the fact that the
defense not only is the defense plan
better but it's taking pressure off of
russell wilson and i think that's key
for him
so another quarterback that's just
quietly now crept back into a potential
contract mitch trubisky you can't really
figure out how or why but they have won
three straight and now everyone's saying
should they go ahead and extend the
fifth year option of trebisky after
they'd already decided they're moving on
from him has he shown you enough rodney
to where trubisky could still
potentially have some piece of the
future there's a chicago bear or is this
all fool's gold
no
he hasn't shown me enough i mean we just
watched him for four years and the
chicago bears a few months ago had an
opportunity to pick up their the fifth
year option and they said no this is an
organization that sees him work the
season practice sees him in the game
sees him every single day so
would i go all in on mitchell trubisky
because he's played the last three four
weeks or whatever it is unbelievable no
he's got to do he's got to get he's got
to beat green bay he's got to beat green
bay because aaron rodgers you see how he
looks how he takes care of his body he's
not going anywhere jack
he's not he's going to be in that
division for a long time so when i look
at mitchell trubisky i might do a
one-year 8 to 10 million dollar deal
with a bunch of incentives if you
continue to go out there and play then
we can we could talk about a definitely
a long-term contract but who's going to
invest 15 20 million dollars in mitchell
trubisky would you if you were a general
manager
i wouldn't and i went back and watched
every snap of that game yesterday to
make sure of that decision but it's it's
pretty clear and there there were still
some very turnover worthy moments in
that game i'm thinking about when he was
rolling right and just sort of did what
i call a jackpot you know jackpot 500
just throws it right up into i mean
there were four jacksonville jaguar
defenders and two wide receivers uh and
it was of course intercepted that was
down around the red zone too like at the
15 yard line but over these last four
games seven touchdowns only two picks
he's completing over like 68 of his
passes which is something that we've
never seen from trubisky they've won
three in a row and maybe most
importantly david montgomery has jump
started this running game for chicago
has been jump started again 351 yards
just in these last three games for david
johnson another big one on sunday
against jacksonville so
is this offense long-term headed the
trubisky route no are they undoubtedly
better than they were with foals playing
quarterback both running and throwing
the football and plus he just gives you
that at any point he's gonna run in for
a touchdown run a big first down of that
mobility factor i think you have to go
with trubisky down the stretch that's
clear and obvious are you gonna go with
them into next year i personally
wouldn't
you personally wouldn't i you didn't
like my idea of maybe signing them to a
one-year you know
low contract for a quarterback
he he still and as much as we still want
to talk about him having a little bit of
confidence on the field to me
you know we've discussed in the past a
little bit of that edge a little bit of
that cockiness a little bit of that
aaron rodgers if you will mahomes some
guys just have that ability to make the
team believe
whether he didn't come into the league
with it or whether he's lost it over the
first few years of his career i just
don't see that confidence from trubisky
when he walks on the football field to
me you can't win anything serious with
somebody like that playing quarterback
see i see a little different i see that
confidence i see what his teammates
describe as that swagger that it's like
man mitch got swag he's playing with
swag that's what his teammates are
saying so it's not about kind of what i
think or what you think it's about what
his teammates think and his teammates
say look this guy's playing with a lot
of confidence he's playing with swag
he's not worried about making mistakes
he's he's kind of like lamar jackson
lamar jackson everybody wants he's
playing loose he's not trying to be
perfect and that's what mitchell
trubisky has always tried to do he's
always tried to be perfect he said you
know what you guys didn't pick up my
fifth year option it's okay i'm just
gonna forget about everything i'm just
gonna go out there and play and if you
don't like me you can cut me you can get
rid of me um if you like me
whatever happens happens and i think
that's what he did he just said forget
it man i'm just gonna go out there and
play obviously um david montgomery
having success running the ball jimmy
graham he's out there making plays like
he's 25 years old like he's you know
heading to the pro bowl so
um i'm like you and i've always been a
critic of mitchell trubisky all i'm
saying is if he beats green bay which is
a basically a playoff game for them next
week and they get in the playoffs
what he's done the last month of the
season
you you almost have to you're almost put
in a position where you're forced to
give him opportunity jack
it's tough so these are the three teams
that they've beat you probably have to
keep some of the context of it and i
hear you on what the players are saying
coach nagy has really talked him up at
moments too but i mean they've beaten
houston who is a team with the wheels
falling completely off minnesota who has
all kinds of struggles in jacksonville
who's going to go get trevor lawrence so
those are the three teams that he's
beaten right here and so it's easy to
get very excited about that
and who's his favorite target too we got
to give a little love to allen robinson
i mean allen robinson quietly having
another huge year with his two
quarterbacks this year being trubisky
and foles he's over 1200 receiving yards
and he's having like 12 targets yet
yesterday 10 catches so that's where you
see trubisky looking for the most part
it's short he doesn't want to go deep
down deal with it it's short easy throws
and for the vast majority of those it's
either jimmy graham or it's alan
robinson and he's just trying to make
these games i don't it's to me it's not
a long-term fix it is a brief spurt
against houston
jacksonville and minnesota three teams
that are at the bottom of football right
now
but they they won those games and you
have to give them credit for winning
those games because we would have
definitely given giving them criticism
if they would have lost those games and
you know it's it's easy to sit back and
and say he only played this but he was
losing games before and these games are
like the building blocks to build you
know just building that confidence and
that's something that a young
quarterback like mitchell trubisky he's
been up and down with his confidence so
anytime that he can play well any time
that he can um you know go out there and
win a game against anybody it it really
helps his confidence and you know moving
forward
and and as huge it is for trubisky it's
maybe even bigger for coach nagy because
if this end of this season had fallen
apart
he may have been on the way out or at
least the conversation would have been
we got to get to looking and i think
he's now played himself back into this
job for sure next year which is a big
thing okay let's get to the pittsburgh
steelers a team that had been really on
that same sort of struggling trajectory
and now turn it around with a huge win
over indy yesterday they were down 24-7
i mean they're just getting crushed in
this game like three minutes left in the
third quarter down 24-7 and big ben just
gets red hot how did he lead this
comeback yesterday to get pittsburgh
right on the right side of all these
conversations
well a big part of the reason why he had
an opportunity is because coach frank
wright he stopped running a football for
the indianapolis coach i remember in the
third quarter i looked at coach dungey
and i said
they're getting four or five yards every
single time they run the ball and then
they'll come right back and pass the
ball and i'm like what are they doing
like and then coach dungey looked at me
and says if they don't throw another
pass they're gonna win this football
game
if they don't throw another pass and
then frank wright went away from the run
he you know put the ball in phillip
rivers hands and all of a sudden it all
fell apart but also um that their
defense their defense in the second half
made no adjustments it was the same
defense over and over again they got
scared they got conservative and they
started playing the same defense over
and over again and big ben found it out
and he started taking shots down the
field because everyone was sitting on it
we saw the game against buffalo their
defense set on every single route that
the pittsburgh steelers did they and
they played against the colts they went
downfield in the second half and it
changed everything for him jack
yeah it really did and this all this
running game for the steelers offense
has been slow and struggling james
connor coming back is big they're not
using him so much as a downhill runner
but they are using him in the short
passing and in the screen game and he
has been a factor there and that's kind
of become the run game for the steelers
offense this year is that they're just
gonna steal about 50 yards it seems like
at least five times maybe ten times
somewhere in between there per game that
big ben is just rising up and just
throwing the ball directly out there to
his wide receivers and it's one or two
guys seeing if they can pick off a db
and go get five yards and they're
stealing 50 yards throughout the game it
almost seems like every game with that
exact strategy of just rise up throw it
to them and just go legend it's how they
build this team isn't it rodney like
juju smith schuster deontay johnson
chase claypool guys that can just win in
space and just go get those five yards
that wound up translating into first
downs and that's taking over what used
to be a steel city power running game
that we're used to seeing as football
fans yeah and what everyone keeps saying
and ryan shazier he tweeted out
yesterday run the d ball run the ball
run the ball like you're telling them to
run the ball but what you have to
understand ryan is they don't have the
personnel to run the ball
up front their offensive linemen are
pass protectors they're not those guys
that's gonna get in the dirt like
quentin nelson and just blow you off the
ball and you you know you're gonna be
able to run for 150 yards like to
tennessee titan's offensive line they
they're not that tight they are past
protectors and that's why big ben has a
nice clean pocket every time he's um
he's in the pocket and he can just throw
it where he wants to but i'm gonna tell
you the other thing that really will
open up the run game
when people start to see them
aggressively attacking the safeties in
the corners down the field that's going
to take that safety out of the box
that's going to put him back 20 yards
and now you're going to have opportunity
so
i think pittsburgh really found
something in themselves the adjustment
that they made just
being aggressive down the field and when
you're aggressive down the field the
corners become a little bit more passive
now that's going to open up the quick
passing game so i think that's what the
you know the steelers moving forward
going into the playoffs that's what
they're going to work with
yeah and on the other side phillip
rivers he's been a great quarterback his
entire career now a couple franchises in
which he's really been a great
quarterback but he's always struggled to
close out games so this is phillip
rivers on the difference between the
first half and the second half when they
fell apart on sunday
if you could have been in the stadium
there was a feel of with complete
domination in the first half all three
phases just kind of like that you don't
you all don't have an answer and we're
not going to give you an answer in the
second half it was like almost we we
gave them a a glimmer of hope and then
it felt a little bit like we were
hanging on you know and obviously you
say well if you felt like you're hanging
on wide then you stop hanging on and
just go push the gas down maybe that's
easier said than done
yeah good teams you know good teams
finish you off when you're a good team
and you have a team like that on the
ropes
you know like the the mindset has to be
when we come out in the second half it's
zero zero it's zero we have to win the
second half don't get comfortable with
your lead and i think that's what the
indianapolis coats did they got very
comfortable with their lead and they
felt like okay we're in control of the
game and all of a sudden pittsburgh came
out firing and ben
bid is a future hall of famer he's a
very competitive guy with a lot of
experience so
eventually he's going to get hot
eventually he's going to start making
plays and that's what happened
it is i almost feel like from big ben's
perspective this is the kind of game
that he prefers the game where he can
just call the offense at the line of
scrimmage throw the football as much as
he wants and just go win it i think with
the the turn around for this steelers
team this is the best defense all year
long the steelers were and then they
lost the speed on the inside in devon
bush and they had to figure out a way to
replace that it throws me back to when
ryan shazier got hurt and just thinking
about how long it took them to replace
his speed on the inside of that defense
you think about losing devon bush you
think about losing bud dupree so they've
had to rebuild and i think they're
starting to rebuild defensively and alex
highsmith one of one of the top graded
guys on the steelers defense yesterday
avery williamson another one of their
top graded guys really great against the
run so they're finding new bodies that
can plug and play those same positions
and the turnaround is happening quicker
than it did when they originally lost
ryan chazier which was just something
that they couldn't figure out now do
they have a devin bush on this team no
but are they figuring out players they
can step in and get good production out
of yes
and that to me makes me think that the
steelers may have a chance here down the
home stretch where before i was thinking
i don't think there's bodies on the
roster to replace what they're losing
there but it's starting to feel like
they might i just don't know they're
getting good production out of the two
that are now stepping in
no i mean what you just said is perfect
because it seems like the more reps um
the more confidence they build you know
you need those reps even if you're a
veteran player and you play special
teams you need on the field reps in
order to build confidence in order to
see the speed in order to read the
coverage i mean um the all the route
combinations and all those different
things and you know
when i look at the pittsburgh steelers
i'm just really proud of them because
they could have turned on each other
they could have started bad-mouthing
each other and i said this last week i
said the most important thing for the
steelers to do is stick together as a
football team they have a good football
team they're going through some tough
times and some challenges but you know
go to your veteran players if you're
mike tomlin have a conversation with
them tell them to bring some young guys
in study a little bit extra more you
know a little extra film and things
gonna work itself out you got big ben as
your quarterback so you're gonna always
have a chance
that's it this offense can score with
anybody and the steelers maybe more than
any other team
fight every second on the clock in a
football game they never go away so 24-7
three minutes left in the third you
better get ready to finish or else
they're about ready to finish you and
that's exactly what they did
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports